[MUSIC PLAYING]
ED COOKE: I'm Ed Cooke.
I'm the CEO and
co-founder of Memrise.
Memrise is a language
learning app.
And it combines a bunch
of interesting techniques
for learning into a very
gamified experience.
So it basically makes
learning any language
joyful and entertaining.
KAI HALEY: Today we are here
at Google for a design sprint
with Memrise.
We're going to
focus on exploring
a hands-free, eyes-free heads-up
experience for their language
learning app.
A Google design sprint
is a tool for answering
a critical business
question through design,
prototyping, and
testing with users.
The benefit here is timesaving.
You don't have to
go down a path,
spend six weeks, two months of
development time on something
that isn't going to be valuable.
It also increases the
viability of the concepts
because you're bringing
together cross-functional teams.
ED COOKE: I think a
dream result would
be if we invented a new
learning mode which could really
take our learners
away from the screen
and give us all some new
ideas for how to get people
listening to foreign
language and spending
more time in the app.
KAI HALEY: On the
first day, we start
by building shared knowledge.
Then we brainstorm.
We do how might we post it,
sharing an affinity mapping,
and a solution
sketch that really
articulates some great ideas
for the new experience.
KRISTINA NARUSK: We are using
our imagination for something
that doesn't exist
yet and trying
to find a solution to that,
and obviously a product
feature that users will love.
How can we imagine the
user using Memrise?
SPEAKER 4: Most of
them use them in bed.
So it could be like a lullaby.
ED COOKE: And over
the course of the day,
we collected hundreds of
these "how might wes,"
which are which kind
of part questions,
part ideas for features.
We were able to
categorize them and look
at the different areas of
the experience which we're
going to want to design around.
KAI HALEY: We try to generate
eight ideas in eight minutes.
And this time
pressure really helps
people to get beyond
their first idea
and push themselves towards
more innovative and interesting
concepts.
ED COOKE: It was quite
astonishing how many
ideas people produced.
In fact one member of the team,
Matilda, had a list of ideas
so long that it would take a
group of 500 skilled engineers
a decade to implement them all.
KAI HALEY: Day two starts
with a presentation and review
of the solution sketch.
We follow that with a discussion
about assumptions and sprint
questions, what we want to
have answered in the validation
phase.
ED COOKE: So, for instance,
we had lots of questions
around the interaction
design, around how
we make the
experience as charming
and fun as the in-app
experiences is in Memrise.
SPEAKER 5: So that maybe
if you're in the tube,
it doesn't sound so
weird, because it
feels like you're
talking to someone,
like, hold on for a sec.
SPEAKER 6: There might be a
cooking mode, for example.
And you say, can it
help me cook Italian?
KAI HALEY: And then
once we've listed
out what the prioritized
questions are that we have,
we will do a voting session.
We ask them to select the
features or the pieces
of the concepts that they're
really interested in trying
out and testing.
That's usually followed
by a discussion
of what will be included in
the prototype and a storyboard
for the user testing.
For this team, we are
doing voice control,
which is really exciting.
AUTOMATED VOICE: Now plug
in your headphones and click
on the [INAUDIBLE]
icon [INAUDIBLE]
to start the conversation.
KAI HALEY: On day three, the
prototyping gets wrapped up.
The user interview
scripts get written.
And we prepare to
put these prototypes
in front of the users.
AUTOMATED VOICE: Welcome to your
first Italian speaking practice
session.
KAI HALEY: And this is
really the part of the sprint
where we see the
most value for teams,
because they are really able
to get answers and validation
to their sprint questions
that they're working with.
We record and capture
all of the content
from the user interviews.
And they're often
quite useful later on
for helping to articulate
why design decisions are made
or why development
decisions are made.
KRISTINA NARUSK: There's
so much goodness that
came out of this design sprint.
You also learn that
one of the ideas
is very much something that
we could turn into a product
feature almost immediately.
I think it was an amazing
experience for everyone.
ED COOKE: And more
excitingly, I think
we've learned enough
about the hands-free mode
to see what it can't
do and what it can do.
Ijust really can't wait to see
the impact of this adventure
not only on our ideas but also
on our communication and just
the general kind of
energy of the team.
It's rather like Meister
Eckhart's approach
to spirituality.
Where most kind of spiritual
gurus talk about a long,
winding painful path to
the top of the mountain,
he had this approach
which was basically
to stick your head down and
to run as fast as you could
and try and reach spiritual
enlightenment the fast way.
And I think it's similar
with a Google design sprint,
is you just kind of go for it.
[MUSIC PLAYING]